No, that privacy always comes
up. People always talk about it.
And I guess I keep going back
to my same point, which was I,
I don't see people like with pitchforks
and torches going down a complaint of
Jeff Bezos that right.
You know,
Amazon's collecting massive
amounts of data or you know,
t mobile and sprint and all these are
our mapping our locations as we move
around. I just don't see it. I mean,
that probably raised nobody's
interest for the most part. You know,
that article that you just pulled
up. Um, and I, I, you know,
I guess in part it's because we, again,
we, we become kind of used to it,
custom to it, so, so fine. But, you know,
what should we be worried about? Well,
I tell you what we should,
boy,
what up mostly is a state
sponsored activity by countries
whose interests almost
never aligned with ours now would include,
China certainly includes Russia.
Who was Iran, the shit that
they're doing. China has a,
a policy, um, information
domination, right?
Which means they've
determined that the next war,
the next modern large scale war is going
to be one by whoever has control over
information. So where are they
putting all their resources?
China knows that they're not going to
build a military that's going to be able
to reach around the globe for the
most part. Although they're, you know,
they're beefing up their resources.
What are they doing?
It's cyber and it's space, right?
So I know a lot of people were,
were kicking the precedent in the ass
and laughing about the space for us
because it is funny, right? But
the uniforms be amazing. But they,
they talk about this,
but China honestly believes and it's
putting their resources into cyber and to
space. What does that mean, wolf?
They're anti satellite technology that
they've been developing and working on
and continue to work on.
The whole point of that is to take
control of communications and surveillance
abilities,
whether it's ours or our allies in the
event of something major that happens.
So they would have the ability to shut
off our SoundLens. No. And if you do that,
then what does that mean? Well,
that means you're blind. Right.
And will suddenly walking around
with campuses and maps, you know,
trying to shoot an asthma, then
figuring out where the hell, you know,
the target is.
So China is currently developing that,
or they have developed something
that they're working on it now. Yeah.
They're working on it now. That developed,
they developed some of it there.
They're working to get
the next generation.
It's like every nation that has the
resources and ability understands that and
is doing the same.
It's not like we're not,
what is their excuse was they shouldn't
do, they don't have an excuse. They just,
they understand. They have the right to
do it. I mean, it's not like they, they,
you know, as long as they don't use
it right. And in an illegal way,
they have the right to develop the tech.
It's like there's no treaty that says
you can't develop satellite technology.
Right. There's, there's, there's the start
tradies there's the nuclear, you know,
conventions that we have with Russia,
which is in a whole nother interesting
topic because we're right now arguing
with the Russians over over,
uh, the, the latest, uh,
nuke agreement that took place
some time ago. Uh, it's, uh,
coming up for renewal sometime soon
in a year or two years from now.
And the Russians had been cheating on a
previous agreement. So we're, you know,
now they try to say we're
cheating on the new one.
And so that's an interesting
thing to be watching.
But the point being is that there's
conventions that try to control the,
the numbers for warheads or for delivery
mechanisms, missiles or, or, or,
uh, submarines, whatever bombers,
but not for this new world.
Cyberspace. Pentagons still trying to
figure out what, uh, you know, a war, uh,
means in cyberspace. Right. You know, how
do you respond? What do you know, what,
what's the threshold, you know, and
then what's an appropriate response? Um,
and so, well, maybe we'll get there.
Maybe we'll start having these discussions
and create treaties that will allow
that. But right now from China's
perspective, again, not to beat on China,
but I'm much more concerned about China
for our national security there a much
bigger concern than Russia is. Russia
is punching above its weight and potent,
you know, Putin is a dick,
no doubt about it. Right?
And they've doing what they always do,
which is metal and democracy.
That's been their methodology for
ever since they've been around.
Uh, but you know, that's small potatoes.
They got the GDP of a small
European country, you know,
and when the oil prices,
you know, are in the toilet, they
really are suck and wind. So yeah,
we gotta be concerned with Russia and
understand that their interests are never
aligned with ours. You know,
for the most part may be.
We tried to imagine they were with
Syria and isis and everything,
but Russia is only interest.
Arrow was maintaining their
leverage and increasing it and not,
not losing their military foothold there.
That was their primary interest.
We mirror our values and we mirror
our interest on other countries.
And so we imagined that somehow we're
all in this fight against Isis together.
Eh, Horse Shit, you know, so, so yeah,
China's a much bigger issue and we,
and we should be focused on that and
to some degree this administration is,
so that's where I say,
look,
you can't just keep complaining
and bitching and moaning
because you don't like
president Trump.
There's certain things that are going on
that you should be willing to say that.
Okay, that makes sense. Maybe
I don't like the messenger,
but that part of it makes sense.
Is it his personal life? I mean,
it was it because of his dealings with
China from the business world that he
understands it better,
that he's more concerned with the,
the imbalance of the, the trade. I
think what happened was what do I know?
This is speculation, so,
hey, but I suspect that what
happened was he came into it,
um, focused on the trade imbalance. Right.
And as he was sitting there and talking
about the trade and balance more of the
conversation from the National Security
Council and from the agency and others
in terms of saying,
well yeah,
this is part of the reason why and
this is the longterm effects of,
of their theft of intellectual property.
This is why in part they've
been successful in these areas.
So I think there was probably more and
more discussion talking about, uh, their,
uh, economic espionage and theft of Ip
and that became then an issue for him.
Um, but I think initially,
and still to this day,
I think the big issue is just he wants
to try to create a win in terms of the
trade imbalance.
Russia seems to us here domestically
leaks, speaking from, for myself, when,
when I think about it,
and I think about the,
the narrative that's been sort of
delivered to us is that Russia is this
military danger.
We're worried about Putin
taking over other countries.
We're worried about Putin's power,
the way he kills dissidence,
the way he kills political
opponents and journalists.
We think about China and even what
the Walway arrests were like, Eh,
no one seems to be concerned. It doesn't
seem to light any bulbs over here.
Yeah, no, you're right. I don't
know why that is, except, you know,
Putin is more like a thug
and he's a visual. Right,
right. And also, I mean, look,
he's, he's been very clear about wanting
to try to rebuild the Soviet Union.
So whether it's Crimea and
the annexation of that,
or where they're taking over
eastern Ukraine, um, eh,
or maintaining a position at Georgia,
whatever it is, uh, you know, certainly,
uh,
you know,
his attacks or the FSB is attacks
overseas against, you know,
dissidents and others. Um,
yeah, he just more in your face.
He's like Tony Soprano. Right,
right. So you can look at that.
China's always been sort of this thing,
right. And Cello, China's fantastic.
The history is amazing. You know, the
places are incredible. I think, you know,
we should be trading with China.
We should be doing a huge amount of
business with China. We should, you know,
clear the decks and try to the degree
we can level the playing field,
but we should also be pragmatic
and realize what they do, you know,
in terms of their, their theft of Ip.
And so, you know, because that again,
that probably won't change,
but yeah,
we absolutely should be dealing
with China all the time.
But I think that they've always kind
of been viewed more in more of a
sophisticated fashion maybe because
Putin has just sort of in your face. Um,
and he's, you know, he's good
at it. He's very successful.
He says he's a smart son of a bitch, but
he's, I think he's pretty easy to read.
Right? He's, he's thuggish
and, um, he, you know,
he longs for those days
of the Soviet Union.
So we should understand that everything
he does is because of that is because
he's, he, he would love to
rebuild the Soviet Union.
And so we shouldn't be surprised
by any sort of, you know,
aggressive move that he makes against his,
his neighbors.
And we should always push
back. Um, and to be fair,
this administration,
not to beat their drum,
but the actions they've
taken against Russia,
despite the fact that you've got people
calling him a puppet of Putin and are
more significant than the
previous administration took.
Like what has he done the
sanctions against, uh, you know,
key individuals and companies
within Russia as an example.
Those are the toughest sanctions
have been placed on Russia ever. Um,
the provision of weapons and a,
and assistance to the Ukrainians,
right? That was something the
previous administration said, no,
not going to do that. You know, cause we
don't, we don't want any blow back. Um,
that's, that's a good thing,
right. That should be done. Um,
pushing back against them on the,
on the 2011 nuke a deal. Right.
And or sorry, on the, on the previous,
on the start deal prior to the 2011 deal
and calling them out and saying, look,
you're cheating on this and you, you
know, you gotta be held accountable.
I mean,
there's certain things there that,
that makes sense then that don't add up.
If you talk to somebody who
says, well, he's an absolute
puppet, and you say, well,
okay, he's a puppet, so why?
Or is he doing certain things that
seemed counter to Russian interests?
And they'll say, well, because
he's smart and he's like,
he doesn't want to get caught out.
I didn't see it. He's playing,
he's playing a long game here,
you know, and he's, and, and,
and I'm thinking, okay, I,
you know, maybe, maybe, who
knows? But, uh, I haven't,
I haven't strapped on my tin foil hat
yet to get to that point. So I dunno.
I Dunno. Yeah, that seems
like a complicated one.
If they have some compromising information
about them, that was always the fear,
right. Is that they knew something or,
yeah, maybe it was business dealings.
Maybe it was people peeing on him or,
yeah. So I'll get them if they had,
if they did not. And again, anything
I can help now in today's world,
anything's possible. Right, right.
And I wish we had somebody else in there
who was more elegant and eloquent and
sophisticated as anybody stand out.
Uh,
not right now.
No.